[Music]
thanks for the very generous
introduction
and I'm very happy to be here it's a
pleasure to talk in front of you this is
not my typical audience I think I know
as few people in the audience as I as I
know one when giving the talk so feel
free to interrupt me if you have
questions so there's going to be a talk
in in two parts the first part is going
to be pretty high-level I just want to
give you sort of an introduction as to
where's quantum or where's the field of
quantum computing these days so that's
for those of you who are not familiar
with the area and then the second part
of the talk I'll get a little bit more
technical and talk about the the title
which is give you a interactive proof
system for quantum computations that has
the the zero knowledge property so let
me start by a by general things so the
field of quantum computing was born in
the early 80s um based on two major
discoveries so the first major discovery
was the is the fact that by encoding
classical information into quantum
degrees of freedoms of physical systems
you can achieve communication secure
communications with levels of security
that do not have any classical
equivalent so this is called sometimes
slightly abusively called unconditional
security with a security based on
physical principles instead of on our
computation of the assumptions so that's
our quantum key distribution and then
the second major discovery is is the
realization that by building machines
based on the principles that perform
computations based on the principles of
quantum
I can explain you could solve certain
computational problems such as factoring
for example much faster than we know how
to do or using classical computers only
and not only this but then also this
hypothetical quantum computing machine
could in principle be built for
tolerantly so in a way that the whole
theory of error correction for quantum
machines that guarantees that you know
these algorithms will be robust to
imperfections in the device well those
only in the 80s or 90s and at the time
all of these were highly theoretical
results so that's one of the first
experiments book for qkd so it's up in
over 30 centimeters and it's absurdly
noisy and absurdly slow but you could do
experiments already in the 90s or just
sending one photon at a time in terms of
computers this we definitely didn't have
so that's the best the best quantum
computers that you had them though in
the 90s was all very hypothetical this
is this what changed I think everyone in
quantum computing has the feeling that
over the past three years for years
we've been witnessing a very fast phase
transition and so we're interested
second era of quantum computing it's a
it's an error that my colleague John
Pascale at Caltech has it has coined a
very popular acronym for so the acronym
is Miss Q it stands for noisy
intermediate scale quantum so this is an
era in which we have these kinds of
devices that's announced not yet
demonstrated by Google where's a quantum
computing chip that has 72 qubits and
the feature that all these devices share
is that they're not fault tolerant so
this is not a full-blown quantum
computer it's it's very small it only
has 72 qubits yet it's large enough that
it's in principle able to perform
computations that we don't know how to
simulate directly so this is ongoing
race for demonstrating quantum advantage
building a machine such as this one that
has the ability maybe not to factor
because that would require a much larger
computer but to solve some computational
problem or some sampling problem that we
don't know how to solve on our own the
classical there's also been a huge
amount of progress in quantum
communication is not something I'm going
to talk about too much in the talk which
is soon to flash a picture this is
a satellite built by the Chinese
government and I think one or two years
ago they demonstrated quantum key
distribution over huge distances so
between Vienna and and some some city in
in China so quantum communications is a
fairly mature field quantum computing is
not because we're still at the stage
where we're we have these kinds of would
secure key distribution well yeah okay
yes yes I mean I'm not going to go into
key distribution so I didn't want to the
question that I want to focus on for the
talk is what are going to be the modes
of interaction between sort of the end
user arm so that you or me with our
laptop and these potentially much more
powerful quantum devices so it's
interesting question how you can manage
to test and verify and control and
interact securely with this kind of a
machine that is in principle much more
powerful than you are and also that you
don't understand so while you can't
perform a direct simulation of it etc so
I'm going to talk about that question on
a sort of fairly theoretical level but I
want to emphasize that it's a very
concrete question this is almost a
techno techno technological problem so
there's a number of companies such as
IBM for example that already putting
their quantum computers on the cloud arm
so I'll actually give you a small demo
of this in a minute so iBM has has a
number of quantum computers that you can
run simulations or not simulation so you
can directly compute with through their
website Righetti is another is a startup
that's that's based in the Bay Area that
also has a quantum computer that's
available through a range of api's that
you can sign up for on their website
Google is promising that once they
finalize this chip I showed you in the
previous slide something similar will
happen so you'll be able to play
yourself with the with the so let me
give you a small demo just to show you
how this works I mean I'm so I'm going
to take the simplest example of an
interesting quantum computation so
here's the quantum circuit so if you've
never seen a quantum circuit before it's
the same as a classical circuit it
operates on qubits which is the quantum
analog of the bit
and then there's a number of gates and
then it ends with a measurement so
that's record just a single qubit has a
single gate and has a measurement but
that gate is chosen so that the quantum
mechanics predicts that the outcome of
the circuit should be a bit
that's perfectly random zero or one with
40 5050 that's the circuit physically if
you want to think about it it's very
simple what you do is you basically just
have a mirror and you beam a laser at
that mirror and the mirror has the
property that is going to split the
photons that hit it our 50/50 depending
on their polarization and so if you tune
your laser so it sends just one photon
at a time the photon is going to hit the
mirror and then it's going to go
straight or be deviated with 4050 so
it's something that is realized and
people build random number generators
now based on this this is a picture of
my random number generator I didn't
bring it here it's and it's at home but
you can now you can bite it this is
constructed by a Swiss company called
ETA complete so that's one of the you
know simplest yet impossible to achieve
classically demonstrations of quantum
advantage so you can generate perfectly
random numbers okay so now let's try to
use one of these cloud computers in
order to do that so I could sort of do
it live but you never know when the
thing is going to be down so although it
is generally pretty reliable so you can
login or create a free account at IBM
quantum experience comm something like
this you can look it up so it looks like
this and then there's a nice little
interface so that's their computer it
has five cubits and the links are which
ones are connected to each other so you
can't do any two pubic gate you want
like only the ones on the links and
these are fidelities of some statistics
but you have this nice introvert where
you can just plot your circuit so so I
plotted my circuit there that's my hard
market that's the mirror and that's the
measurement and then I'll click you know
run and then like a few seconds later
IBM gets back to me and says ear while
we run your circuit and here are the
results so we run it a few times and we
got zero with probably the point five
zero two or point five zero two fraction
of the time the number of times we run
it and one was probably deep or forward
[Music]
[Applause]
so question is when we talk about
quantum advantage what are we comparing
with and so either the best that is
currently known to be achievable
classically so that would be for example
Danzig factoring where I would say
there's quantity bantered or are there
explicit lower bounds or may be based on
some conjectures or in some some
complexity theoretic assumptions because
I'd have to at least separate right so
generally it's I guess it depends what
you want but if you want to concrete the
demonstration then this will be against
the best known classical lower bound and
people have these braces where there's a
quantum problem that's demonstrated you
can do it with 50 cubits or 60 cubits
and then the question is well you know
the classical runtime is going to be 2
to the 50 or 2 to the 60 but then what's
the constant in the exponent
oh well in that case I wasn't doing it
was talking about a loved one I was just
saying about the best on the best
achievable so if there's no bounds then
you mean you need to make assumptions
and if you want to complete lower bounds
then you may need to make concrete
assumptions for example the assumption
yeah you need to make complete
assumptions as to a specific problem not
being really good take factoring for
example and make the assumption that you
need to have put something explicitly so
you need you need to do that later also
for other problems like this this is a
little bit different right because
that's not computationally difficult
it's impossible to generate oh my
computer can do it look at the weather
is weather we believe these statistics
all right I mean how did IBM come up
with these numbers that they just do it
the way I would do it reasons like take
a piece of paper do a calculation and
say well it's supposed to be 50/50 if I
tell my user that it's exactly 50/50 s
then they look suspicious so let's so
that's an interesting question um so
just to you know summarize what's going
being going on here is that the way we
think about it this is this is me with
my laptop it's the anti here we call it
verifier interactive boost in general
interacting with the IBM quantum
computer and I have this circuit that
I'm interested in and I'll give a
description of this circuit through the
IBM quantum computer and the IBM
computer is going to return to me an
answer so it'll tell me how it got zero
and then run it another time insane it's
got one and then I run it multiple times
and then I can reconstruct the
statistics that I had one go on your
previous slides and so once you've set
it up in this way then there's a number
of questions that you need to ask
alright on the first question would be
okay well I mean is this outcome that
I'm observing correct or not so in the
case of a simple circuit like this I can
check I can I can I can do the myself
estimate what the distribution should be
and I'll check it against the
distribution that's reported by IBM but
that's because this is a pretty simple
small computer and my circuit was very
simple so didn't just do the computation
by hand now if I take a little bit of a
slightly larger computer that IBM is
also offering in the cloud I can also
still simulate that using my calculator
so that's pretty easy now we take a
slightly larger computer I think this
one huh let's go computer I was
some people in computing people
announced lots of stuff and then there's
a fixed X sort of not clear whether it
happens so this one was announced at CES
like January Monday's January to January
before I know there's anyone from Intel
here but I don't I don't know of
anything that happened to it so various
so if you manage to do this and then you
compute what is the amount of space that
you need in order just to represent the
state of such a machine then you get
something like 70 terabytes okay so you
can still simulate these machines on
doing the best
supercomputers that exist today we go to
the chip that's promised by Google 72
qubits and if you do the computation
interestingly you get 600 hexa bytes and
so that's just about the size of Google
data centers worldwide are sort of like
a rough estimate so Google can still
simulate our in principle as their chip
where they're probably the only ones and
if you make it just a little bit bigger
than no one will be able to simulate it
anymore so the question is well can you
device protocols such as even though you
can't simulate this process directly
yourself are there ways that you could
verify that the outcome is this query yo
could you test it with other smaller
quantum computers I mean that's a
question known that you can ask so yeah
I mean I guess that's the question that
I'm asking here I mean it's not I have
four questions I won't lightly focus on
that question but there's a lot of
research in me yeah doing similar things
yeah you come in all the t wait no an
expert on T wave machines I don't have
anything interesting to say about it
okay so no questions okay so that's one
question right and what makes it
difficult is this sort of exponential
scaling but it's the reason that were
interested in is computers in the first
place right that we achieve or in
principle things that we couldn't
achieve classically well another
question slightly more subtle question
is well our media I'm interested in not
only if the outcome is correct or not
but was it obtained correctly or not and
that's the question that's relevant for
the randomness 5050 is correct but in
order to certify that the outcome that I
get is random that that's not a property
of the outcome itself it's a property of
the process that generated the audio car
there's a little cartoon here if you can
read it that that sort of makes this
very vivid what they're saying is that
look I mean if you're supposed to be
generating around the numbers and IDM
reports that they got nine nine nine
nine nine nine nine then on what basis
are you gonna complain about that number
right this is it is it is a number that
has okay it's perfectly legal okay so
that's the the verification questions
and then we have the security or privacy
questions one question would be well is
there a way to delegate this computation
that I'm interested in to the computer
in a way that preserves the privacy my
privacy of the computations so that
hides the computation that I'm
interested in there will be an analog of
for morphic computation for example and
then there's the flip question which is
the zero knowledge question which is is
it possible to implement protocols that
that that that achieve this some can
verify delegation of computation in a
way that they have the zero knowledge
property so in a way that Google is able
to just convince me that they're
reporting the correct outcome of the
computation without leaking any
information about how they achieved or
how they arrived calm this will be a
little bit more formal so we're going to
be thinking about these kinds of
interactive protocols between a
classical being and the quantum computer
where the classical entity is interested
in determining what is the outcome of a
certain quantum computation that they
have in mind represented by your circuit
and so here are the list of properties
that we like I mean the most important
one maybe is though is the somnus which
is that at the
of the interaction it should be the case
that as long as the verifier accepts
then the outcome of the competition that
it records is the correct outcome so
there's no way for this machine to
convince the verifier of the wrong
outcome even though it's it's it's more
powerful than to verify result a
slightly more subtle would be convincing
the verifier that the outcome has the
right distribution or has been obtained
in the in the correct way whatever
whatever that means and then there's the
privacy guarantees so the first one that
I mentioned earlier is John referred to
as blindness so this would be designing
such a protocol in the way that the
verifier does not give any information
to the the prover to the quantum
computer about the computation that it's
desiring it to compute and then the
other one that we'll focus on in the
talk is the zero knowledge property
which would guarantee that the verifier
does not learn anything about the
computation other than the outcome with
knowledge of X right blindness means you
don't even know what that is exactly the
way power dogs right of course but the
approval would not know whatever there's
a simple bit of a performer of the
computation knows it when you could try
to have both properties simultaneously
and so in that case we have both
blindness and zero knowledge it would
not bullet which is no line oh yeah sure
yeah we could do that so right now
they're independent probably to me they
see not that each one should hold on its
own it's gonna there's a our situation
where I want it to be performed you
don't even know what it is but I also
not supposed to know anything about what
you did
so what having both they don't
understand the applications I understand
each one separately no I mean in zero
knowledge it's more that so in general
knowledge you think of the verifier is
being dishonest so it would be you know
yeah yeah yeah yeah but but
the verify is requesting a complication
right
there's no idea what he's request right
in addition and now we want to put a
constraint at the same time on the
verify that you won't know how that
complication was before and everyone
okay each one is separate but okay it's
not maybe I miss formulated zero
knowledge is not be that you don't want
to learn how the computation was
performed but it's that you don't want
for it to be feasible for the verifier
to learn something more than the outcome
or is the pair acceptor that is they're
all in good yeah that's right so I think
I want to think of them as being
separate you know you say I want to talk
in you is about zero knowledge not about
blindness
no wait altered I mean the reason that
good is there is just to say well what's
interesting about specifically more
about zero and other genu is in the
quantum setting is that for those of you
who are familiar with Paz your knowledge
proofs they often involve the use of
simulators and in particular proof
technique that's called rewinding so you
execute the protocol in a certain way
and then you say well you know let's
pause let's rewind on the actions of
this device and let's ask it another
question and see what it would have
answered on to that other question and
in this way you've managed to construct
your simulators so that's the point
that's particularly tricky in the case
where the device is quantum because we
cannot rewind on these quantum devices
in general so especially when the
interaction is classical so the device
is going to perform measurements in
order to determine the outcomes that are
sent back to the verifier and these
measurements are non reversible so we
will have developed a whole set of
techniques to deal with this difficulty
of making rewinding arguments go through
in the in the quantum case so let me
just say a little bit about the kind of
give you a flavor of the kind of
protocols that have been built in order
to solve this problem of verifiable
delegation of quantum computation so
this light is not about blindness or
zero knowledge it's just about achieving
softness and you have to think that our
starting point would be the situation
where the verifier itself has a quantum
computer that it trusts because it's its
own and so in that case it would be able
to run the whole computation by itself
and there would be no problem at all
right and so what we're trying is to
design protocol is that off offload as
much possible as the quantum computation
to the cloud so there's been a lot of
work on that question in angel it's a
very challenging question so some of the
first works are due to our own oven
culture and then the other is a
broadband Fitzsimons in cash EFI arm
where they design protocols they'll have
the following flavors so the vampire is
still has a very small quantum computer
but the only thing that's required of
this computer is the ability to prepare
one quantum state at the time one qubit
at a time
and then send it over to the poor um and
then the verifier does this it sends
only state to the poober then the prover
makes the computation based on these
states and then the verification happens
through classical communication so the
effort of the vapor is mostly classical
except for this preparation of wine
stays there's kind of a dual our family
of protocols that with those pioneered
by MOA and Fitzsimmons we're now the
prover does the whole point of
computation themselves but they're going
to send one qubit at a time to the
verifier who's going to measure these
qubits as soon as it receives them and
then based on the outcomes that are
obtained perform a classical computation
so there's no classical interaction
there and then determine what is the
outcome of these two types of protocols
involve a little bit of quantum ability
for the verifier and some quantum
computation and so forth fairly long
time it was a big open question whether
you could design protocols that have
only classical communication so the
first type of such protocol is due to
wine card Rijkaard winner was Ronnie
2012 and they showed that if you are
assume that you have access you are able
to query to quantum servers that are in
isolated locations yet something known
as quantum entanglement then you can
have protocols for delegated computation
that our information theoretically sound
and only require the exchange of
classical information there's a drawback
to that which is that you need to have
these two servers they need to be in in
isolated location so how do you
guarantee this again for a long long
time this is the best that was known
then just last year Madoff was a PhD
student here introduced the first
protocol for the delegation problem in
which the verifier is entirely classical
and there's a single quantum improver
that so that's required the protocol has
a little bit of a different flavor than
the other protocols I'll get to it a
little bit later on in the talk it
doesn't work directly in sort of the
most intuitive way in the circuit model
where you direct this Pugh ver to
perform certain gates one at a time this
also it takes a more global approach
where you're going to require the prover
to prepare a certain quantum state that
contains in it the that certifies that
the outcome of the computer
is a certain thing and then the prover
is going to reveal information about
that state classically in a way that
allows you to verify the existence of
the state and as a corollary the fact
that the computation had a certain
outcome it depends what that qubit you
ask you physically or it depends what
that qubit is made of I mean you can
think of if you think of a protocol with
communication then usually photons would
be used so you can think of this quantum
computer as a solid state kind of
computer I mean it's a big it's a big
thing you know in the fridge but then it
has the ability to be more photons just
like using a laser or something to the
verifier and the vapor just needs a
mirror arm to justly measure where the
photon arrives so these these
measurement devices are this is very
easy to make the one the picture that I
showed you earlier contains one you can
you can buy such things
the quantum communication I mean in do
quantum communication link and so
experiments have been done for
demonstrating these kinds of protocols
on very small machines before so it's
definitely a technological challenge but
it's not a huge in principle the last
one I mean this one here
based on the entire computation right
yes but the size of that thing is as the
site has decides the number of gates in
the computation all these protocols the
verifier has runtime that's generally
even polynomial maybe quadratic or cubic
in the number of gates of the
computation difference is that it's
classical runtime of course not wanted
right although the number of the same
thing the number of qubits that you need
to process in these protocols is
proportional to the number of gates in
the circuit but it's one at a time yeah
you can just get it measure it then keep
cask information get it measure it keep
classical and then do a large classical
at all so people haven't really
investigated on the option of having you
know sub linear super efficient
peripheral or even probably longer to
make yeah so one one reason is that the
these three protocols involved no
computational assumptions at all and so
achieving these kinds of efficiency
gains if you don't make computational
assumptions that I don't think the last
one does and so in that case you're
saying well you know if I if I do make
computational assumptions then why don't
I make my verifier even more efficient
why I think this is sort of work to be
done still so as we mentioned the last
protocol which is the one that I'll talk
about a little bit later
doesn't make computational assumption of
course you want your computational
assumption to be your post quantum
computation assumption and so concretely
the assumption that's made for that work
is that the learning of various problem
is is posed to our security so that's
that's a problem you know in lattice
cryptography maybe Daniel even mentioned
an advantage of the protocol that's
going to be relevant when we start
talking about zero knowledge is that it
allows verification not only of quantum
computation efficient quantum circuits
but also problems that are in quantum
and being so that's the class that's
called qmail define this a little bit
later where you're trying to verify the
existence of a certain quantum state and
as long as the prover has sufficiently
many copies of that quantum witness then
it can demonstrate to you that so some
of these protocols have the blindness
property not all writing the first and
the third have the blindest property
none of them has the zero knowledge of
property so this is something that had
not been studied so much before and so
it's it's what I want to talk about for
the for the second part of the top there
are there's questions about this now I'm
going to go into just like concrete
protocols try to stay fairly high level
and understandable for those of you who
don't have the background in quantum
computation but let us see if we manage
so so I sound over already gave a very
nice introduction to what it means to
have before protocol to have the
zero-knowledge protocol he didn't give
you an example and so I'm gonna give you
an example I know this is bread and
butter for a lot of people here okay
sorry okay okay yeah sorry okay so Jim W
okay
good parts McCauley and okay I'm going
to give it to you because it's a if
you've never seen it it's nice and also
because then we're going to try to build
on it to make it into a protocol for
testing or language that's in quantum
quantum version of NP and said which is
the classical version of NP which is
though the three colouring problems so
our input here is a graph for example
this very simple graph and what we're
trying to determine is whether the graph
is three colors where are the three
coloring of the graph is just an
assignment of colors to all the vertices
you have at most three colors such that
each Edge has endpoints of different
colors so how do you do that it goes in
in three phases at the first phase the
prover is going to determine a valid
three coloring and then send to the
verifiable commitment to that coloring
so commitments already arose in the
alesandro's talk you can just think of
as a big safe that's placed around the
color and that is sent to the verifier
and this safe needs to have for this
commitment scheme needs to have two
properties that it's hiding and biting
and we're going to see how they're how
they're used so then that the second
step the verifier is going to challenge
the prover to open two of these
commitments so he's going to select an
edge at random for example this edge
there and ask for the prover to provide
keys that open these two safes and
foobar is going to oblige are reveal the
keys that open the commitments the
verifier is going to open the commitment
and check that it sees two distinct
colors along the edge so why is this
protocol sound meaning that the prover
would never be able to convince the
verifier that the graph is 3 colorable
when it's not this relies on the binding
property of the commitments which is
that when the verifier receives these N
safes as many safes as there are
vertices in the graph then in principle
these safes are hide certain colors that
it cannot see that the hiding property
but these colors are there are fixed and
in particular if the colors do not
correctly color at least one of the
edges then there's always a small chance
that the verifier would choose that edge
and challenge to pool for the edge and
then the prover would get caught and
then so that's where the sound is
probably I mean if you want this gives
you a loss owner so you're gonna get a
better sound this should repeat the
protocol multiple times and now the zero
knowledge property this is interesting
because there's two ingredients that go
into it the first is that at the time
when you receive all the commitments
then that's your hiding property of the
commitments you have these big safes and
they reveal no information at all about
the coloring well later you are asking
about some information what you're
saying is that well please don't please
open this edge and show me these two
colors so you are learning what are the
colors of the end points of that egg in
a3 coloring of the graph now the key
observation is that this three colouring
problem has a very nice structural
feature which is that if you have a
three coloring you can take any random
permutation of this free coloring it's
still a valid three colors and if you
choose the permutation at random the
colors of just one specific edge these
are going to be uniformly
you turn over all the three possible
valid colorings of that edge so the
prover does this if instead of
committing to a specific coloring it
commits to a random permutation of a
specific coloring then when the verify
opens the edge it doesn't learn anything
about the original coloring that the
pulverizer so this is perfectly zero
knowledge this is zero knowledge mother
I'm sorry okay okay so now we want to
try to do the same thing in the quantum
case and so before doing that I have to
tell you a little bit about the kind of
problems that we're going to be able to
try to they were going to try to verify
in a zero-knowledge way so that's the
class QA it's the quantum version of NP
was introduced in the in late 90s by key
tile so let's let's first just like
remind ourselves what NP is so in NP
though the setup is like this so you're
given as input a formula think of this
formula as a set of constraints so these
Phi J's are constraints and then the
formula is that the and of the
constraints should be satisfied missing
for example for my three colouring
problem each of these is the constraints
that a particular edge should be colored
using different colors and then my
general formula is just that all the
edges are should be colored correctly
and so our boiling three coloring is to
decide whether there is an assignment of
the VAR to the variables that completely
satisfies the formula and more generally
the max case that problem is trying to
find an assignment to the variables that
satisfies the largest possible number of
constraints let's talk about the the
quantum version now so if you think
about these formulas are putting
constraints on the physical system the
physical system are the variables the
constraints are that these variables
should should should have colors that
satisfy certain constraints so in the
quad case we're going to represent that
by a Hamiltonian so Hamiltonian is a
word that's used by physicists to denote
the way they the mathematical object
that they use in order to represent
physical constraints that are imposed on
the certain physical system like for
example the magnetic field and nearest
neighbor interactions and these kinds of
things for us is just is just a matrix
think of this as a matrix that says what
are the constraints on the system
so just to do it pictorially in my three
coloring example I had a state space the
state space was you know three colors
for the first vertex three possible
colors for the second vertex three
possible colors for the
vertex and my problem my formula imposes
constraints on that state space right it
says that okay these two should take
different values and that would be a
constraint one case is exactly the same
thing except that you make things
continues so instead of having a state
space that's discrete and has three
possible values that have a state space
that's the vector space C 3 and as I
mentioned three and instead of taking
the my total state space instead of
being the cross-product would be the
tensor product and it's not really
important if you don't get them the mad
about this because I'm going to stay
fairly informal about it and the
Hamiltonian just puts constraints on the
state space so it says that well you
know this the part of your system that's
in in that space should should satisfy
certain constraints you can think of
this if you only think about the math
you can think of this as a projection
operator that is assigning a penalty of
one to states that you don't like and a
penalty of zero to states that you do it
in this projection operator is diagonal
in the computational basis then you
recover classical these are a strict
generalization of classical so our goal
given the input is to determine what is
the smallest eigen value of this matrix
in physics language we call it the
smallest energy of the system so we're
trying to determine whether this matrix
has an eigenstate that has low enough
overlap so that corresponds to small
eigenvalue or at least so that the
overlap there's when makes the problem
difficult is that in general if you've
paid a bit of attention this matrix is a
matrix that acts on the space that has
dimension in this case 3 to the n so
it's an exponentially large matrix so in
principle you can solve this eigenvalue
problem in exponential time and the
point is that if you have a quantum
computer given this eigen state that
minimizes the energy then you can
perform measurements on it that
correspond to this Hamiltonian and will
tell you or allow you to estimate where
this dark energy
so oh yeah okay would be the number yes
so I haven't really said that so this H
needs to be you need to be able to
specify these constraints efficiently so
it can't just be any odd exponential
size matrix so I'm assuming that he has
a decomposition as the sum of local
constraints kind of in the in the
classical case and then this local
constraint acts on a certain subset of
the particles in my system and K is the
number of us okay would be to Windows
but I don't think we need to be too
formal about this right the picture that
I wanted to give is just the picture
that what we're trying to determine now
is is very much analogous to what we're
trying to determine in the case of three
coloring does there exist an assignment
to the colors that's to the viral to the
vertices that satisfies all the
constraints except here that the
assignment is the quantum states and the
constraints are constraints so let's go
back to our protocol from the previous
slide it'll make everything quantum and
see if this works or not so it almost
works um so that's the problem that
we're trying to decide um the prover is
going to come up with this quantum state
which is the best quantum assignment to
the quantum constraint satisfaction
problem and so again I'm gonna have a
protocol that goes in three phases so
the first phase the we want to prove our
to send the commitment it has to be a
quantum commitment now so we can do
these quantum commitments if you choose
the way to do about it the way to do it
is to encrypt the quantum state are
using the quantum version of the
one-time pad so that results in a
quantum state of the same size and the
quantum one-time pad uses a key just
like the classical one-time pad is the
classical key except it has twice the
length because you're including the
corner function so what the pouvez will
do is that it would encrypt each of
these qubits they're using the quantum
one-time pad and also send the classical
commitment to the classical strings that
are used to encrypt the quantum state
okay and ship all that the way fire so
it's that's quantum communicate
communication
another way I would say well okay let me
choose one of my constraints at random
for example this one and let me ask you
to open the commitment so the prover
would return to you the encryption keys
the verify will check that they match
the commitment would use them to decrypt
the state would perform the measure
and would check that it satisfies the
constraint the way it should satisfy
Australia so this protocol is sound
that's fine um the commitment that I
have there I'm not I'm not cheating
about it it is it is a binding it is
also hiding so this protocol has sonís
and let's talk about zero knowledge now
so the original commitment that's sent
that also reveals no information the
point in one time fired is it perfectly
hides on the quantum information so
there's no problem there the problem is
about this last trick that we used in
the gmw protocol the randomization of
the colors right so in this protocol the
vampyre still gets to do two things one
it gets to choose what edge it opens
what constraints it looks at and second
it gets to choose how it looks at it
right because the prover opens the
commitment now I see the state and clear
in principle I should be making a
certain measurement that's the
measurement that's encoded in some
Estonian but in practice to verify I can
do something else it can do another
measurement and maybe that measurement
is going to reveal more information
about the point state so we don't have
in the quantum case such a nice problem
as the three colouring problem where I
could just say well let's just like
randomize the state and be done so that
makes the question a little bit more
interesting and so now I want to tell
you the previous so there was some
random choice for the colors in some
sense oh you mean the provers choice or
yeah when you open it it turned out it
was very increase the next time oh I see
mhm
so you say the problem is with the very
far away measures the next no it's not I
mean that would be a problem but it's
that's not even a problem the problem is
even more basic is that there's no dis
randomization that could be done doing
the coloring problem cannot be done here
so even just in the one-shot case I
could make a measurement that reveals
more information about the state in a
way I'm going to not only learn that the
constraint is satisfied but it can be
satisfied in many different ways just
just like in three coloring and I'm
going to learn this specific way in
which it's satisfied and that's
revealing some information unless I to
do a similar randomized
trick that is not something that we know
how to do or the quantum states I mean
okay it did you believe that we don't
have with their other languages out
there that might support some
organization yeah that's a good question
um could you formulate a property and
maybe study the class of languages that
have this property and maybe if they
it's not empty then it something weird
happens or so you're going to see how I
get around this in the next slide and it
could be that based on that you could
devise such a language I'm not sure so I
don't think that question has been asked
this interesting question if you're
interested in so I see two problems are
this one is like the commitment should
be reserved to be part o crew fear
well at this point I'm interested even
in a quantum zero knowledge proof what
right at the end we'll or depending on
time maybe not but we'd make the proof
classical but you're right I mean it's
something that maybe I want it to be the
interaction to be classical but for now
let's be satisfied with a corner
interaction commitment there should be
one to Brazilian to begin with
otherwise the Cougar could yes my second
finger is to say is it to say that there
is not an allergen on the permutation
but a classical settings that were to
archival first by permuting things once
you reveal them then I get you know the
same distribution of colors no matter
what
but there is another thing with the
Blake act of mewling itself
I hope you at home and you never know
what I've done so here even if it is a
physical error or two per unit so it's
once you reveal it they can be it could
be the active commuting if it exists it
could be leaked amazing ye if I'm now
not only crossing over also there is
some leakage suit right so we definitely
want to prevent that yes so we'd want to
prevent it that is very high yes yes
yeah so much is not yet to grow a the
permutation doesn't exceed that and to
it exists this should also be the case
there is no point to maybe it's both
completeness and soundness focus okay
let's see how we do it or how it how it
can be done in the next slide and then
we can you can ask a question so this is
the protocol that you to broadband G
some watches 2016 and so we're gonna
we're gonna take the attempt from the
previous slide and sort of fix it in
order that it's on recovers to zero
knowledge probably there's gonna be two
changes um the most important one is
that we're going to change the way this
commitment works by adding a layer of
authentication so instead of just
encrypting the state I'm gonna also
authenticate it
using separate key for the
authentication and then what all keys
are classical and then commit to the
commit to these classical keys so this
authentication is going to require a
couple properties that we're going to
see what they are as we go to though the
protocol okay so I'm making a slight
modification to the way the commitment
procedure is okay so then we had like
the easiest problem to deal with that we
had before is that the verifier has the
option of choosing which term it wants
to verify and that's already giving it a
little bit too much proverb power to a
dishonest verifier compared to how this
very far so we're throwing in a coin
flipping protocol here that's a
classical protocol between the verifier
and the poverty
to install that the verifier chooses the
term that it requires that it requests
an opening for uniformly at random
that's pretty straightforward we do that
so the prover and the verifier jointly
select the term to be opened and then
the poor is not going to give any
information about commitment at this
point the very far is going to directly
perform the measurement on the
authenticated encryption of the state so
here you need a special property which
is that this authenticated encryption
even though it does not reveal any
information about the underlying state
it allows you to do what we call the
transversal measurement which is that
you can perform if you're interested in
a specific measurement measuring this
specific term you can perform a derive
the measurement directly on top of the
authenticated encryption such that if
you have the outcomes of the measurement
and you have the keys then you can
decode back to the actual measurement
outcome that you were interested in so
the verifier just measures directly on
top of the authenticated encryption on
top of the commitment if you want and
then it's going to obtain outcomes and
then just return the outcomes or to the
proverb and then at this point are the
prover has the outcomes that are very
far obtained and it also has the keys
that it is attached to by the commitment
and so it's going to engage in a
classical zero knowledge proof that is
going to demonstrate to the bear fire
that it holds keys such that these keys
match the commitment and furthermore if
you decode the verifiers outcomes under
the keys then you obtain outcomes on the
original state that satisfied or that
satisfied the quantum version so that's
the end of the protocol the Sumner's
are realized now in two things first of
all the binding property of the
commitment as before and second now we
also need this zero knowledge protocol
to be sawn and to be sound against our
quantum adversary's so we need such a
protocol and for the zero knowledge
property then we have the two
ingredients that are introduced so one
is the will be the soundness of the
coin-flipping protocol and second is the
authentication so that's the second
property we need of this authentication
I mentioned the first property was that
you can perform these measurements on
top of it the second property is that
measurements on top of the
that I guess that's more of the what
this authentication achieves is that if
the verifier attempts to perform a
measurement that's not the measurement
that it's supposed to perform then when
it sends the outcomes to the prover the
prover is going to determine that the
wrong measurement has been performed
think about it as inserting traps in
this this authentication uses traps and
but then it's encrypted
and so if the verifier performs all
arbitrary measurement is going to hit
the traps and approvers going to detect
that and refuse to decoder the outcomes
to verify - yeah what you're proving in
three is that these days why we did not
be an MP statement oh no no no it right
maybe I didn't write it very clearly but
no no so these are these outcomes if you
have all the classical information at
this point you can classically verify
that the stating polls so you have the
outcomes you have the keys you decode
the outcomes to a certain value you
interpret that value as the outcome of a
measurement on the quantum state and you
check if it's the outcome that you
expected so it's entirely classical so
it is it is you reduced it equal to
classical classical yeah
so I have five minutes I mean the last
step maybe maybe I'll just do some of it
okay I do it sort of orally so at this
point what we've achieved or what they
have achieved in their work is a quantum
protocol that uses a quantum verifier
and the quantum prover that allows the
quantum verifier to determine that the
prover holds the witness for a certain
language in in qma and in a way that is
sound and that has the zero knowledge
properly and now what we want to do on
top of that is we move all the quantum
stuff that the verifier has to do so
remove the need for quantum
communication and remove the need for
the verifier ought to be quantum so
let's look at where there's something
quantum going on here what the prover is
quantum obviously it's repairing this
eigenstate so all this but that the
prover doing it but it's that step right
when the prover sends these
authenticated qubits to the prover and
then the only thing that the prover does
about the authenticated qubits is that
it measures them and then immediately
afterwards it returns the outcomes to
the floor so what we need is a
commitment scheme that would have the
following properties we need the
commitment to be in a sense to a quantum
state but we'd like it to be using
classical information alone so you can
be given to the verifier and then it
should be the case that given the
commitment if the verify relator is
interested in obtaining measurement
outcomes for a specific measurement that
it cares about on the quantum state that
was committed to it's able to do that
using a classical interaction with the
prover in a way that the prover is a
bound committed to reporting measurement
outcomes associated with the states that
it has committed to and with the
measurements that the verifier is asking
without being able to change its mind
about either of them if you had such a
thing we just plug it in and sort of be
so this is what is behind the mahadev
protocol for verification that I
mentioned earlier so let me tell you
what is a classical commitment scheme to
quantum states on that slide and then
it'll be sort of straightforward that we
can plug it into the previous protocol
maybe
so the scheme has the following
properties basically achieves what I
described earlier so it's just came
between classical verifier and a point
improver the quantum hoover has a
quantum state and so the scheme is going
to work as follows first of all there's
some public public parameters so this
this scheme is going to be based on the
harness of learning a various problem so
you need to sort of instant shape to
this learning of various problem and
tell the approver about it given the
public parameters the prover has the
ability to perform a certain quantum
operation on its quantum state that
results in two things one is another
quantum state that is sort of the
quantum part of the commitment and then
the classical string that's the
classical part of the commitment because
our vampire is classical in the approver
can only send the classical part of the
so as the commitment phase and then now
it's an interesting to try to define
what's a commitment to quantum states
when you can't send the quantum state
over so instead that now there's going
to be two options for the verifier the
vapor is going to have the possibility
of selecting a measurement that it's
interested in in quantum computation
basically there's only two measurements
that you need to care about they're
called the X measurement and the Z
measurement isn't matter or if you don't
know what they are there's just two
sufficiently incompatible measurements
that all the richness of quantum
computing is captured by these two
measurements so while her protocol
allows the verifier to do is to request
outcomes according to one of these two
measurements or either a next
measurement at which point the prover
can perform a certain measurement on the
quantum part of the commitment send back
classical information which orders these
outcomes such that the verifier can
given the value of the commitment and
the response decode these in order to
obtain
outcomes of making the X measurement
directly on the quantum state and then
you have a exactly analogous thing where
the verifier could request measurements
in the in the Z basis so what she shows
is that it is possible to instantiate
this scheme like this based on the on
the learning of errors
so there's equations we're missing
something
so before we use for heaven itself
multipolar scheme right nietzsche about
classical very tired but as you
correctly say the difficulty is how do
you know of it this is a two covers are
separated particularly separated with
the one community stop Jesus just
separated so they're just separated when
you need to check is that they're just
like basically space-time sir okay but
even if you take separation desire yes
so therefore you say I want to reduce it
now that the reason a classical guide
verifier and there is a single Cooper so
there is no issue of separation but you
do you do this if I why can't I as a
militia very higher the form a joint
measurement on everything you do and not
gain some information so I can hear by
polling this is structure say do this
measurement and you return that you've
done best measurement to know others and
things are possible but why can't I so
you give me this like a dresser these
are three states and I think it somehow
I I solve it whatever it needs I do some
strange measurements directly prefer
whose eye is in the verifier interpreter
so here there's no point in
communication so there's nothing to make
an imagined at all but that's king
specifically enforceable so in other
words oh so no so here the only thing
that could go wrong is if the verifier
can't definitely have a quantum computer
of course but then the only thing it
could do is use that quantum computer in
order to break say the learning various
problem and I would defeat to the
protocol I don't think there's anything
as it could do it could it could attempt
to send quantum states to the prover but
if the puah is being honest if there's a
way that the prover can always
immediately measure the quantum states
that it receives them treats them as
classical information
so you prepare some Cubans to say rate
you'll beat you is the verifier you you
are the proven by toxin or the proven
okay okay okay so then I interact with
you in a specified manner but what he
why can't I do directly some quantum
measurements on your triplets or qubits
no when you prepare a coverlet asking
you anything you could it be a famous
question like the question before in the
world there's a spawn to bits and plenty
measured because it's in the world so
look I'm Adam Trombly because you use he
for different entities and you use he
for different entities and so I'm having
trouble exactly so if you're talking
about the verifier and you're saying why
can't the verifier measure the provers
qubits directly I mean these qubits are
in the possession of the prover okay
varying your position but that stuff is
he believed in the world even though I
think that's a basic misunderstanding I
mean it's like the you could tell me the
three colouring protocol is not sound
because what if the verifier goes sort
of inside the provers mind and looks at
all the colors that it must have
prepared in order to create separation
what I'm saying is beta isn't the case
over I mean the assumption is exactly
the same that the prover has a physical
space that's its own physical space and
of course the Hoover and the verifier
have separate maker experiments in your
space sorry if this was implicit I mean
I think the same assumption is made in
it's not a stronger assumption these
quantum systems cannot be you know
observed any better than classical
systems by it not being there in the lab
so if I have a fridge and there's a
table in front of it or something that's
that's whenever like something that
guards the fridge oh god sorry
okay so thanks to you so and I really
hate to be taking over lunch so I'm
gonna the the next step is to plug this
back in the pre the protocol from the
previous slide and obtain the classical
protocol there's a few hurdles that you
need to overcome to put the pieces
together but I'll skip that and just
directly conclude maybe if I just have
one minute for the computers sorry this
is no no well I said one minute okay so
what is the point of the talk right so I
started off by saying well you know we
have we're at this interesting moment in
time I think truly um where quantum
machines are being built and we don't
exactly know what these machines do
right because they're very hard to test
very hard to verify because of two
things exponential scaling and the fact
that quantum information is difficult to
observe directly you make a measurement
in the information gets destroyed then
the things are being built and they're
there on the cloud and you can play with
them and so in essence in question to
determine what are going to be the modes
of interaction with these machines
certain result that I that I presented
is a zero knowledge protocol where the
verifier is entirely classical has
computational soundness and it applies
to any language that's in our QA so the
quantum version of form so some
questions there so maybe the blindness
question I should set aside because it I
think you're right actually that it's
interesting what happens if you combine
the two of them another question is
whether applications for these kinds of
protocols one thing that zero knowledge
proof czar used for classical ease for
grading schemes that have CPA security
two CCS security it's interesting
whether that could be used for schemes
that are quantum encryption schemes and
trying to get CCS equal in the quantum
case that we very delicate to define CCS
secure the CCA security game in the
quantum case where I think it's an
interesting question there are also
questions you can ask about proof of
knowledge interesting feature of the
protocol that I didn't get enough into
to show you is that the in order for the
prover to succeed in the demonstration
that it has the witness it needs to
perform measurements on this witness and
these measurements are in general
destructive that's a consequence of this
quantum commitment protocol
so in order to succeed in the protocols
we need many copies of the quantum
witness and you're going to destroy them
I think it's an open question whether
you could design a protocol as classical
communication such that the protocol
does not destroy the witness okay then
there's more practical questions but
these are all
[Music]
[Applause]